here's the story from the New York Times
lab leak most likely caused pandemic
energy Department says the conclusion
which was made with low confidence came
as America's intelligence agencies
remained divided on the origins of the
coronavirus I love they have this
picture of the virus Factory in Wuhan
the Wuhan Sheamus Coughlin tweeted
remember when a virus emerged outside of
this uh in the city next to the virus
Factory and they told you you were crazy
for claiming that the virus may have
come from the city with the virus
Factory it seems crazy but anyway so
here's real quick just to do a couple
things we get into this conversation
I'm not saying I trust the government
okay the doe is saying this is most
likely and I'm like I agree it's just
one agency saying it's probably the case
and it probably is the case but I want
to show you these archives take you back
in time you want to read that one Ian
this is Tom Cotton keeps repeating the
coronavirus conspiracy theory that was
already debunked The Washington Post
reported this February of 2020. they
said Senator Tom Cotton repeated a
fringe Theory suggesting that the
ongoing spread of the chronovirus is
connected to research in the
disease-ravaged epicenter of Wuhan China
cotton referenced the laboratory in the
city the Wuhan National biosafety Lab
blah blah blah blah blah so uh about
that you should just then we have this
one from his like Banner on Twitter oh
he should New York Times Senator Tom
Cotton repeats Fringe theory of
coronavirus origins in an interview on
Fox News the Arkansas lawmaker raised
the unsubstantiated possibility that the
new coronavirus originated in a high
security biochemical lab in China and uh
the New York Times February 17 2020
called it a fringe Theory and today or
so there's a couple days ago it was 26
yesterday lab leak most likely caused
pandemic what's it called when you say a
bunch of stupid things and then have to
New York Times And The Washington Post
have edited those articles to remove
their stupidity from them because uh
yeah everybody's basically saying well
uh the virus probably escaped the place
that make coronaviruses I remember
seeing this on Taco Carlson right around
that time it was either the same day he
made that statement of the day after and
thinking to myself this makes the most
sense there's a lab there people don't
really understand how many leaks occur
at biosafety Labs even here in the
United States I mean that's that's how
people believe uh
what's the disease um lime Lyme disease
yeah a lot of people think Lyme disease
was the product of a of a BSL lab leak
that's on an island off the coast of New
York there's one in can I mean that was
a big thing for a while they were
building one in uh Fort Dietrich you
don't get to make all these movies where
the the scientist gets pricked through
their suit and they go oh God and they
run out and then have people think these
labs are completely safe yeah Lyme
disease was uh found near Lyme
Connecticut right and that's why they
call it Lyme disease they don't know
exactly where why I wouldn't be
surprised if it was I've heard the same
thing that it was done on an island like
a biomedical it's just like the idea of
federal government's like but that only
happens in movies movies are based
completely on fiction we would never do
anything like it yeah even this
announcement it still says we have
concluded meaning it is done that it
might have happened over there we don't
know it's the ultimate soft launch of a
like explanation right you know some
girls like soft launch their boyfriends
on Instagram the government is soft
launching the that they're admitting it
was from a b testing we're low we're not
sure but we've done all of our research
and we're basically right so what it
what if what's the likelihood that this
is a a Cassis Valley
for war with yeah this is a definitely
an opening for a war for sure um so if
they needed one well right so setting
the stage think of it this way if if
China invades Taiwan how does the United
States get the American people to
publicly support a war with China blame
all of covet on them exactly remember
that that you know your parents who died
it was China yeah we just found that out
and then people are going to be
screaming in the polls and the media
will come out they'll March in lockstep
but uh sure enough you're still going to
get actually this is interesting let me
walk I was going to say something
different I'm gonna walk back a little
bit I'm curious would conservatives
remain anti-war if the U.S government
came out definitively across the board
and said we have direct evidence that
they were breaking international law
with with gain of function research and
they caused the global pandemic I think
so because a lot of people know that
fauci was working with Eco Health
Alliance to do the research so it wasn't
just the Chinese a lot of people are
aware that Anthony fauci and probably US
government was involved as well so I
think that that will be a loud noise
being made and statement that's repeated
like fauci was involved in this and so
what I'm asking is the U.S will want to
go to war with China over Taiwan
will conservatives now support
internationally actually I think it's
the opposite and I think that's the
reason that conservatives wouldn't
support it because like for me
personally I would say well why are we
going to war with China uh until fauci
is playing on trial and until all
everybody in the United States that had
any part in this is dealt with then we
can talk about China but only until that
happened that's what I mean it would be
hard to sell that going to war would do
anything do anything right right like
we're gonna send more people to die
after putting them through everything we
have the past three years it with war
and maybe this is just a very
rudimentary understanding of it you know
it's not like we'll take a chunk of land
from China and then we'll be like and
that solves everything for kovid right
like I could see issuing tons of
economic sanctions I could see breaking
trade Partnerships but actually going to
battle with them I actually feel like if
you just said it's about Taiwan there
were more Americans who'd be like okay
sounds good then if you said yeah that's
why I brought up the people knowing that
fauci was involved in and financing and
working on the stuff through Eco Health
people would not want to go to war
because they know that fauci was
involved so that would be like I'm not
gonna buy the crap you can't pin this on
China we know that there were American
scientists involved in building this
thing at least for evidence points to
that well there were fauci provided
funding and Eco Health who then provided
funding to wuhan's yeah or whatever they
pay you to pay him to pay him and do it
for me it's virus laundering or
something I think really what this is is
just the the long tail setup for their
plan for the 2024 election and I mean I
was thinking about this a year and a
half ago where
um especially if Trump runs again
they're gonna they're gonna put covid
and the vaccines and all of it on Trump
that's what I think uh I I think they're
going to say hey uh he left fauci in
office uh he pushed the vaccine through
uh too quickly because he wanted uh to
Puff his chest up and show how good he
was and look at all these people that
died as a result of Trump's ego uh so
it's all his fault it's going to be just
like you know projection is their own
what a tool so what if they come out and
they say we have now confirmed Wuhan was
doing a legal gain of function research
with the assistance of Anthony fauci
through circuitous funding and thus we
will be filing subpoenas and criminal
referrals for Anthony fauci and then
said after they arrest him we are going
to go to war with China so let's say
let's put this way China invades Taiwan
the U.S says we're going to defend our
allies in the region but we can't be
directly involved with China oh whoa
China the virus on purpose and caused
all this damage and hey what's that
fauci was involved fauci you're under
arrest hey guys can we go to war now
I don't know I I gotta be honest with
you I think conservative I mean I
wouldn't really describe myself as a
conservative particularly but I think I
think the the sort of Warhawk side of
the party is uh is getting smaller and
smaller I mean you know with everything
going on in Ukraine and
I just I don't I really can't see a huge
number of people being especially China
I mean you're talking about two World
superpowers it feels like opening
another endless war right like didn't we
just get out of the Middle East in some
respects and we're already spending more
money in Ukraine than we lived in
Afghanistan I just can't you know it's
so there's so much media now that you
know these the days of like the Gulf of
Tongan and these things where they can
stage an event and they can get people
riled up and there's they've got this
like dead zone before the truth really
comes out and and then you get momentum
going and people are so uh afraid to go
back on what they said you know they're
like it's like the sunk cost fallacy I
just think that that time is coming to
an end these days I think everything's
on video I think the US I don't I don't
know maybe they're just realizing they
can't keep lying about this because any
sane Jon Stewart goes on Colbert's show
and says this makes the most sense but
I'm wondering I guess I guess I just put
it this way my prediction would be in
the event the US does want to go to war
China invades Taiwan the U.S comes out
and says oh heavens oh the lab Lake that
was China's fault the majority of the
Maga side of people
which includes some Libertarians
Independence they all say no war
and then your McCarthy's and your
McConnells your Lindsey Grahams are just
like everybody was ragging on China just
10 minutes ago and we can't allow this
you can't change your mind and now act
like they're the good guys and then the
Democrats are going to come out and be
like China's always been the bad guy
what are you guys talking about
conservatives You're such you're always
defending Xi Jinping and Hillary
Clinton's like I loved Vladimir Putin
all of these years well no they'll still
hate Russia but they're going to come
out and be like why won't you support
our Wars and then every journalist every
news Outlet's gonna come out every poll
is going to be like we surveyed 5
billion people and found that 95 percent
want war with China so if you don't
agree you're a weirdo and then you're
gonna get a bunch of Normie people and
cities being like Oh yeah okay I guess
World War III or whatever I bet if they
that if they were to be like and by the
way Anthony fauci is involved something
something Anthony that should be like
and by the way I have documents of
Barack Obama being involved Bill Clinton
being involved I have evidence of the
Clinton Foundation being like if it was
all she is the Nexus of this stuff and
he knows everybody nobody that's working
on this I mean he's he's very
specifically NIH but it would be funny
if just like some guy no one ever heard
of shows up and then he just starts
putting out all this evidence on all of
these people and it's like
the government's actually run by someone
like some Shadow government no one ever
heard of like like an Epstein level guy
I mean because the the reality is that
there's probably some big corporate
lobbyists shout out to Woody Harrelson
he's talking about these cartels there's
probably some big corporate lobbyists
that you've never heard of Black Rock
State Street Vanguard whatever who come
to these people these politicians tell
them what they need in exchange for
funding and you've never heard of these
people yeah and they'll send someone to
talk to the politicians so the
politician doesn't even know who the
people are so it's not even like Shadow
government conspiracy level stuff it's
like we know these big investment firms
exist we don't know who's doing the
principal lobbying
but the politicians do yeah they know
who's coming to them and telling them
like look we need this bill passed
otherwise your Pack's not getting 100
million dollars and they're like but if
I don't get that I don't I don't win
you're right so better get the bill
passed and they go you got a boss so
they're already uh don't those guys
already investing in Ukraine BlackRock
and oh yeah what an opportunity it is
and think about the war debt Ukraine's
gonna have no this war is actually it's
it's all it's more like the US is
Conquering Ukraine all the money being
given to Ukraine will justify the U.S
owning the whole thing or I should say
Europe and NATO owning the whole thing
because in the event that Russia loses
Vladimir Vladimir zielinski is going to
be like yay freedom now don't forget you
owe BlackRock a hundred billion dollars
yeah and you will never pay it back well
just like China has the uh belt and Road
initiative right where they're uh
subsidizing the building of
infrastructure in third world countries
especially in Africa they're
um they're paying for the cell towers
and the freeways and that's because they
can get the data from the cell towers in
particularly but
um yeah they want them to be beholden
and I think uh that's sort of what what
we do is we go in and destroy everything
first and then we rebuild it in the way
that that we think we want to in the way
that benefits our investors and uh these
big Capital firms so you know we're fine
to watch Ukraine get shelled into
Oblivion which is what's happening right
I mean uh because not only do they have
the 100 billion in debt already but
after the war ends our firms or
shouldn't say our but International
firms come in and say okay now you're
going to rack up another 500 billion in
debt as we rebuild your country for you
yeah and we will own you forever they
don't they don't they're not going to
have the infrastructure are left at the
end so the the fact of the matter is
they can't rebuild their country without
concrete plants and you know steel uh
fiber optics all these things that
they're not going to have the capability
to make so we can go in there and do it
for them and uh that's that's really the
profit motivation for those people to
build a smart grid to track and data
yeah smart grid right we got to upgrade
it you know everything's going to be
Wi-Fi wireless now and uh you know it
used to be that the U.S would invade a
foreign piece of land and liberate it at
least in one instance the Spanish uh
when they the Spanish-American War at
the end of the 1800s they went into Cube
by the Americans and they liberated Cuba
from the Spanish Empire and Cuba became
its own thing the US didn't even want it
they weren't like pay us back as far as
I know they didn't want to extort them
or anything so Kubo is free and then
Cuba became communist and very dangerous
for the Americans so we've kind of we
should invade it so you're saying I'm
wondering like when we do go into
liberate is it better that we leave
Americans there to control it or do we
actually just let them be totally free
because Freedom isn't free we have
freedom in the United States because we
have dudes with guns pointing them at
all the bad guys and forcing this area
to maintain the semblance of what we
have defined as Freedom maybe we should
like invade
these countries and then put our troops
there for 20 years and then build
military bases all around 30 years 30
years because that doesn't work either I
mean not really South Korea seems to be
working with Puerto Rico did we do that
what we should do is invade the country
and then uh hand an AR-15 to every
single Citizen and say now you guys are
on your own
I don't know you've got a fair fight
with the government now you have what we
have which is the only thing that has
kept our country from being different
from the rest of the world we're going
to liberate You by we we're going to
install the Second Amendment uh the
First Amendment and the Second Amendment
and then we're gonna I don't think it
will lead you to your devices I don't
think we don't think so nope the the the
American colonies had moral structures
and shared culture shared culture uh
moral foundations and classical liberal
principles they were they were shared
among the founding fathers so they were
kind of like leave me alone and that
worked you go to a place where it's like
authoritarian religious Fanatics and
give a bunch of guns then you're going
to get 15 different sex just shooting
each other non-stop for 50 years I'm not
saying we should go there and change
things I'm saying cultures need to
develop and get to that point there's
perhaps diplomacy that we could employ
that might help you know put them in a
direction we think would ultimately
reduce violence and increase Prosperity
but I don't think guns a First Amendment
probably
give people the right to speak freely
share ideas and you doesn't exist though
without the second yeah that's the
problem I mean I think that's right no
that's a good point yep we want them to
be able to speak freely when the
government comes to beat the crap out of
them yeah I think it's hard to accept
that if we were to go into a different
country and say you guys are free to
decide what you want that they may
install system that number one doesn't
work like do we go back then and fix it
and also they may Pick A system that we
don't like right like if communism is
what ultimately Cuba decided would work
I'm not saying it did but that was what
came out on top when they were allowed
to pick
you know
I would not if I were you know John
Kennedy or whatever I would not want to
be like ah yes Cuba you just have your
communism and hang out over here while
we have democracy but on the other hand
you just keep going in and saying like
no you have to do it our way you have to
do it all right you have to do our way
especially like we were saying before if
there are countries that are dominated
by cultural or religious pressures that
are so dissimilar to what we were
founded on like we don't have the same
kind of basic needs that other other
civilizations do I was I was talking to
Ali London on uh the culture War podcast
with Tim Poole check it out on Apple and
Spotify and youtube.com timcast one of
the interesting things he said to me uh
Shameless plug was that in Korea they
all get surgery to look like European
people like they'll get their their
chins shaved down and they'll get their
noses look at nose and plants make their
noses bigger and they'll get their eyes
made to be wider with surgery so they
can look like white people and it's a
normal thing for all of them we thought
it was like we talk about how crazy it
is that a British guy would want to get
surgery to look Korean but to him he
said he was living in Korea that was
normal
everybody was there was getting surgery
to look like the specific thing so he
was trying to look like they were
I don't think uh the U.S occupying South
Korea whatever you call whatever you
want has necessarily been good for them
but certainly it's been better than if
it was North Korea that and you know the
Communists that took over so
yeah I don't know it's like they went
the complete other other direction but
it's still better I guess it's tough to
talk with confidence about life in Korea
because I've never been but from you and
me parks first hand perspective she's a
North Korean Defector I guess you call
she was able to escape the country
because you can't leave freely uh I I
believe that North Korea is absolutely
one of the biggest pieces of Hell on
Earth of Any Nation well and South South
Korea yes there are Western beauty
standards that become a part of culture
but on the other hand like America has
never generated anything like the K-pop
industry right producing K-pop stars who
then go through plastic surgeries to
look American like we we didn't we never
message like Korean culture is still
strong and it has some interpretations
of Western influence but I would never
say that it's lost its culture to a
western identity I went to uh
a shopping area in Seoul and they had
this advertisement for like Chicago
pizza and then one of the pizza
varieties was black squid ink and I'm
just like we don't we don't have that in
Chicago but you know it's it's tourist
stuff no way yeah it's like I went to
Thailand I went to get Pad Thai and I
was like I want squid and then my Thai
friend started laughing at me and he was
like bro it just means like shrimp
noodles like you're asking for shrimp
and noodles but like imagine ordering a
cheeseburger but with chicken just order
a chicken sandwich and I'm like in
America we have like Americanized Thai
food you know what I mean so he's like
you want to go get real Thai food and
then he brought me to an actual
restaurant and we sit down and you know
what you know what real Thai food is it
was steamed chicken and rice I was in
Brazil and I was like I want real
Brazilian food it's like all right we
got steak and rice yeah there's like
nothing complicated about it like people
around the world typically eat a lot of
this similar things different spices
depending on the area but in America we
dump sugar fat and oil on everything
spice it a certain way and we're like if
there's like brown sugar vinegar Ginger
it's Chinese if it's Curry it's Indian
but in reality it's like not really I
think a lot of the Indian food was
invented in Britain anyway there's a
really interesting documentary about uh
the spread of kung pao chicken and like
how that was developed and especially
as you came to America and you had these
Chinese restaurants there were a couple
really high-end you know culinary
experiences but a lot of them were
considered sort of cheap or convenient
meals and they spread throughout the U.S
and those they had to come up with a
dish that was like palatable to
Americans that they would eat but also
wasn't so complicated that they would
not need it it's similar to uh the man
who founded Taco Bell
he was like I'm going to uh he grew up
in California and he grew up wanting to
have a hamburger stand he was like a kid
in the depression then he went to war
and then he came back and was like their
Hamburg stands everywhere so I gotta do
something else and there was a Mexican
influence in the area he grew up in and
so he was like I'll make tacos but I'll
make them with flour tortillas and with
lettuce and basically like made it the
most simple like it gets compared to a
hamburger it's not really a traditional
a Mexican taco but at the same time it's
something that people will eat and they
recognize flavor it's not too
intimidating I'm pretty sure when they
introduced Taco Bell to Mexico they
called it American food thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time